hi welcome to the meeting
i'm so happy that you're able to join us
today i'm kathleen swanson
i'm a member of the project santa fe
foundation faculty
and i want to take you on a journey for
the next 30
minutes to basically talk about
how lab medicine can play a role in
value-based health care
how can your lab pivot to be an imp
transition and this change that's
happening in medicine today
and how you can do this through
meaningful insights
that product provide information at a
population health
level so let's go on this journey
i'm going to basically talk about seven
issues
in our discussion the next 30 minutes
i want to cover what's behind this
movement that we're seeing what's
driving this
i want to talk about what the meaning
the definition of meaningful clinical
insights are
so that we're all on the same page we
have a great starting point that way
i want to talk about specifically how
you can use this in population health
and then we're going to talk about some
things that will help
you do this in your laboratory how do
you move in this direction
so let me cover the background first
this shouldn't be anything new
to any of you on the meeting today
but let's just talk about what the
current environment is
and and how that's helping us move in
this direction
so currently both payers
and payment models are moving from a fee
for service kind of basis to a
value-based reimbursement model
in the united states about
50 of contracts are now being reported
as having a value orientation to
it with more occurring each year
the the challenge is this is lab data
is still being perceived as a commodity
in this environment the discussion is
around
the cost per test and what's the
turnaround
time it's really not around what the
value that lab data can bring to the
table
and so we need to help shift this
discussion
in this direction we also know that
health care costs are totally
out of control way above the gmp
above any other components that we
see at the same time we know that health
care
resources are stretched they're limited
there's only a certain amount of focus
that we can give
and there are some people that would
actually advocate that population help
health that movement will help us
in the move in the direction and support
value-based healthcare
and then i don't have to tell any of you
but the kova 19 pandemic
on top of all these other challenges has
been really
interesting what we see now is lab being
thrust into the limelight
and we have an opportunity to shine from
this
so let's think about what our current
lab information systems do
for us and what's the current data model
that we often use
the literature does have a couple of
data models that are reported
but for the most part these models talk
about
a transactional lab information model
what does that mean we get one test
in one order and we produce one result
out it also talks about in the
literature
significant problems and challenges
because of
lack of data interoperability across
healthcare
we can't share data very well and we
really need to think about how to move
that in a different direction
what i want to do today is talk to you
about how to think about remodeling your
data
how do you use a different data model
in order to have longitudinal
diagnostic insights that's a key
word that we're going to frequently go
back to
in our discussion today so if you think
about that for a second let me give
you some examples that will help
anchor our discussion so
can you imagine remodeling the data
so that you could see a patient's
results
regardless of who the provider is
but all done in the same laboratory
what about different treatment locations
what was done in the er what was done in
the primary care office what was done in
the inpatient
that could be really valuable for
preventing
repeat lab orders providing
insights across provider lines
think about being able to see the
patient's total picture of health
or care based on their lab results
could you look at the course of a
disease or condition
over time what if you could look at
their diabetes over the last three or
four years
and see if the patient is in control or
out of control
what if you looked at data
across time even if it was within the
normal range
laboratorians have a tendency to think
about data that it's
within the normal or outside the normal
above the normal below the normal but
what happens
if a calculated creatinine clearance
was being looked at as increasing
even though you're still within the
normal range
and what if you could use the data to
actually screen patients for disease
so here's some ways to think about
different ways
of presenting sign
i want to talk a little bit more about
the remodeling of lab data
and i think this is an important thing
to think about because
you have to take some baby steps before
you can
look at the larger picture so the first
is to think
about presenting these clinical
diagnostic
insights on an individual one-patient
basis
so can you use this information
specifically
to do a targeted intervention on one
patient
is this patient a pre-diabetic that
you've
you're screening and now you're going to
diagnose them
as having pre-diabetes and now what do
you do for that one patient to monitor
that
over time once you get that one patient
component down
the next step would be to move into a
population health
kind of look at the data so this
this one patient at a time helps us
set the stage for the population health
view
now moving along this continuum is
basically
occurs because of the data analytics
capabilities
so we need to think about the data
individually for the patient
first and then at the population health
level
so let's talk now for a second
i know population health in many
countries is much further along than it
is here in the united states
but i'm going to address basically the
u.s market
currently and and how we think about
maybe some population
health issues so population health can
really support clinical decision making
for groups of patients
but many people would say well wait a
minute we have all of this
claims data that we could use to support
population health
and they'll argue that they don't really
need lab data to support population
health
because they have the claims data here's
the challenge
claims data is delayed one to three
months
so it's not real time it's not even near
real time data
the second that happens with claims data
is
um in in the experiences that that
i've had and that we've worked with
different groups we can see a documented
error rate
of as much as 25 percent in the claims
data
so if you're going to use this to make
population health initiative decisions
around the claims data provides us a
significant problem
if you think about using lab data for
population health
we can use it across the whole spectrum
of a condition or a disease
i think i've mentioned just a minute ago
you can use it for surveillance
of that population you can use it for
prevention
of a disease or a condition can you stop
patients
who are pre-diabetic moving into a
diabetic range
because you can identify them early and
prevent
the disease from moving forward and can
you use it to monitor
treatment now i'd like to you to think
about
using this data in a focus
that has to do with chronic and high
cost conditions
i think this is really where population
health can play
an important role with the lab data you
can look
at a disease where the health care
system
is having a challenge solving it and and
and yet it is costing the health care
system a lot of
money and if you focus by thinking about
how how this data can improve patient
outcome or decrease the total cost of
care
that really gets us to the mark of where
we need to be
so let me give you an example what if
you could identify
a condition or a disease upstream before
it's severe
what about something like chronic kidney
disease
you have the capability currently to
identify patients
in early stage chronic kidney disease
and prevent them from moving into
stage three or stage four slowing the
progression of that
disease can you do that through
surveillance or prevention
with the existing systems and mechanisms
that you have in place
maybe but in general i would say
i would argue that most lab information
systems are underprepared
to move in this direction and that we
should be thinking about this
i wanted to find for you clinical
diagnostic insights
we're going to talk about four
components
that are currently part of a paradigm
described in the literature as clinical
lab
2.0 in this clinical lab 2.0
leverages their clinical data to support
disease management and to improve health
conditions
for a majority of issues that have to do
with chronic disease
that cost us significant
amounts of money in our health care
system and have a heavy burden
for health care what we want to do is we
want to take these
lab 2.0 components
and we want to focus on early care
we want to focus on prevention and we
want to focus on well care
not once the patient is down the stream
and already in sick care or hospitalized
so let me take you through the
definition of these four components a
little bit
i'm going to talk about wrist
stratification
so given the fact that labs are
currently dealing with covid
right now tell me just think for a
second
can you think about can your lab
stratify patients who were positive for
covid
and have concomitant heart disease
i'll let you contemplate that for a
second so we have two totally different
arenas two totally different
um conditions that many patients have
so can you look at concomitant health
conditions
that lend the patient to being at a
lower risk or a higher risk
can you look at health determinants that
are existing
in the lab data set do you know if the
patient lives in a
rural area where they have challenges
getting health care these are some
examples of how you could stratify
risk for existing patients in your lab
data
the second example that i want
is gaps in care i actually love talking
about gaps in care
i am a clinician by background and
training
and so it's interesting because what we
think about with the lab data
is not just what the patient
has orders for and what data we have
but if you think about what gaps in care
is it represents
testing that the patient doesn't have
but really needs
if you had a patient with diabetes and
you were following the ada guidelines
it would recommend that the patient be
tested two to four
times a year for hemoglobin hba1c
values right so the question on the
table would be
can your lab look at a hemoglobin a1c
and tell us how many patients
do you have where they have actually
been tested
sufficiently to meet the treatment
guidelines
that's a good example and i love using
that one because the information
really demonstrates that when it comes
to following chronic diseases in health
care
we don't do a very good job we also have
the opportunity to support performance
measures things like hedis the health
care effectiveness
data and information set now this is a
measurement set for health plans
um to be able to measure their
performance around
and oftentimes data is insufficient
to be able to help
metrics and so the lab can really play
an important role
in that
the third clinical diagnostic insight
that i want to highlight
that's part of the clinical lab 2.0
component is that of being able to pick
out patients that are high risk
these are patients that are already
unfortunately downstream
so they might include things like risk
signals like
a lot of er visits or patients who
require
higher levels of care currently and can
you intervene on those patients
to prevent future care from
needing to occur by being some having
some preventative measures
you can think of lots of examples for
identifying high-risk patients in your
[Music]
population
the last component of clinical
diagnostic insights
is to be able to take the information in
order to
generate um focused care which we call
facilitated intervention
i don't unfortunately have sufficient
time today
in order to discuss this but i do want
to
just mention that i think the lab has a
huge opportunity
to be able to provide care to patients
and work with
others to provide focused care for what
the patient needs
because of the frequent touch points
that the
lab often provides to the patient
okay so now that we've talked about
why we should do this and
what our clinical diagnostic insights
that could be provided i wanted to talk
about the ingredients that you may need
in your laboratory in order to move this
forward
most important are your people any good
administrator would tell you this
right so what you're looking for is an
integrated innovative team
let me say that again integrated
innovative team if you would like to
tackle this strategy
in your lab that is the building block
for all
future next steps you would want to
incur
encourage subject matter experts to be
part of this discussion
so this would be pathologists clinical
scientists
but you also want people who are experts
in the workflow process if you
thought about setting up a hepatitis
screening and treatment panel
that could occur with a single order
in your laboratory how difficult would
that be
to manage that workflow process
i often find that the people who are
direct frontline employees involved in
workflow
are those that are the most beneficial
for the internal teams
the second that you may want to consider
too is people outside your clinicians to
participate in this integrated team or
committee that you
may want to set up so billing and
finance
they often provide excellent insight on
what you can
and cannot bill for like if you were
considering screening labs
the legal team really needs to be hand
in glove with your integrated team
they need to understand data management
and sharing agreements
that you may need to work through and
any repercussions associated with those
we often find that pharmacists
can have a significant role in an
internal lab team there are
a number of laboratories here in the
united states who have hired pharmacists
as part of their internal team
and you might say why pharmacists well
pharmacists are trained to manage data
they look at treatment decisions
and evidence-based strategies and and
what's the right decision to make around
that
and maybe more importantly drugs
represent
currently about 27 percent of health
care dollars spent
so if you're going to use your lab data
in order to
generate changes in total health care
costs there's a huge opportunity here
lastly and and maybe most importantly
you want to have some data analysts on
your team
people that really understand the data
these
these individuals are difficult to find
um
uh i've had some luck um in my
uh career time to work with some who
really understand this
and um and they are they're very
difficult so if you have them hold on to
them
they can be part of your hospital-wide
um
system your informatics system but
um the challenge is if they belong to
your hospital
they may not have sufficient time to get
to dedicate
to this initiative that you want to push
forward so it's something to think about
second ingredient is your data process
proper so um i would put a big
big gold star by this one this often
limits laboratories in their ability
because they have insufficient data
analytics capabilities
internally and they're tied to their
information system which prevents them
from managing
this data in a way that's meaningful um
what they what we would really like to
see
in an ideal scenario is to be able to
use
um data analytics really in a meaningful
way for clinical care
um and the problem is is that this is
not clinical care as the lab
sees it this is clinical care as the
clinician
sees it and when you look into the
literature what we often see is
clinicians say they spend too much time
in the emr
not enough time with their patient and
that when they have to manage
a complicated clinical patient
or let's just use an example of a
patient with chronic kidney disease
they often cannot apply
the clinical information for that
disease
in front of the patient at that moment
in time
so what you need is you need your data
analytics to be in real time
in order to support this a lot of
organizations have a data repository
but most data repositories are built for
billing or actual
actuality or data and i didn't say that
right
um you know to to be able to manage that
from a clin
instead of a clinical standpoint from a
financial standpoint
and so um you want to think about what
components of a data repository are
needed
you also need a robust enterprise
master patient index so
what's that all about it's reducing the
data silos
that we have i can get this data but i
have to go to finance
i can get this data but i have to go to
this part of my organization
so how can you bring this data together
in your data analytics to make it useful
and then how can you use this
information to stratify these patients
to look at a community viewpoint
we've talked about what you need inside
your lab and we've moved a little bit to
maybe what's
outside the lab with your data
scientists
but i really want to focus now on
external partners that you're going to
need to be successful
you have to solve problems that are
important to your external partners
i've had a lot of examples where i
thought we had a great idea
to be able to work with someone on but
we weren't in alignment with what was
important to them
and so really what we want to do is we
want to ask ourselves
what problem are you solving for them
for your stakeholder or for your
customer
what are what's their pain point what's
are they meeting their quality measures
are they not meeting their quality
measures
and if so very specifically what areas
can you help
in is your organization looking for ways
to
decrease emergency room visits or
decrease
hospitalizations for a certain subgroup
of patients
or maybe for everyone if they're on
fully value based contracting
and i would encourage you to look at
partnerships that you've already
developed
those existing relationships can really
move you
far into this discussion of
meaningful clinical insight creation um
some other ones that i have on slides
that you can think about is you know
working with your administrators do you
have a seat at the table
with them to help them understand the
value of lab
data have you tried reaching out to
partners such as health payers or health
plans to see what
and have you reached out to your
information
analytics people they often have great
data
but they don't know how to use it and i
think you can really provide support in
that way
let's see let me move through these
slides a little faster we're going to
talk about measuring value
and what i would generally find
is that measuring value could be both a
clinical value and a financial value so
clinical value could be
things like reducing emergency room
visits or hospitalizations
improving the patient follow-up and when
we talk about financial value i really
want you to think about
savings not within the lab we're not
talking about
decreasing cost per unit cost of
the lab test we're talking about
decreasing
total cost of health care expenses
so an example might be could you
identify a patient
early on in their disease or condition
so that
when they get further down in this
disease you can actually
save that emergency room visit because
you have a way to monitor those patients
similar to what's being done in some
cases in healthcare currently with
heart failure or chronic kidney disease
i want to give you two examples the
first one i'm going to talk about
is a recently published paper with
diabetes surveillance
in this paper the lab took
five years of longitudinal data
and they retrospectively examine this
data
to see if they were as good
if not better than using the cdc
model of identifying
diabetes and the cdc model
uses what they call brf ss
data or burl's data you'll hear it
referred to
at times and in this study
using lab data alone to for
diabetes surveillance they were able to
get a
a percent of identified diabetes
equal to that of what's considered our
current gold standard
which is the cdc brf ss data
the other advantage was that this data
was really accurate
because it was based on lab results
although it does present a challenge in
that it's a population that's being
measured
for hba1c and it may exclude patients
that are not being measured so it's a
great tool
to be able to use for a population
health initiative
around diabetes just by looking at your
longitudinal data for surveillance
the other example that i want to give
you
is in pregnancy this information that
i'm sharing with you
has come from a special supplement of
the clinical lab news
it's part of what was presented in 2019
as part of the univance healthcare of
excellence award
and the goal of this project was to
identify patients
early in their pregnancy in order to
ensure
that they had adequate follow-up and
monitoring
with their lab testing and their
physician visits during their pregnancy
and this was it with a goal to decrease
prematurity
in this um and to save total cost of
care
in this case there was significant value
in this study because we were able to
identify patients
early in the disease condition um
about 15 14 of patients were identified
prior to the existing system and
we were able to decrease prematurity and
close
up to 60 percent of their gaps in care
with this data
now i failed to tell you at the start of
this discussion
is that how this process worked is the
lab
had a partner which were a health plan
chair coordination group that
specifically
focused on care for pregnancy and for
pregnant patients
and so this collaboration led to these
great outcomes
this isn't easy um i want to tell you
that there are
barriers to being able to do this and if
i didn't present
at least some of these barriers it
wouldn't be a fair representation
of the challenges that the lab is up
against
um i think that um it's it's
oftentimes people have great ideas but
the ideas are too large
to move forward so you really need to
think about how to do this in a small
way
in a small pilot at first i think
it's a you know patient care is
lots of spinning wheels and dials
and so one of the challenges is to
isolate
what role the lab has helped in that
particular patient's care
the example that i gave you about
prematurity with
pregnancy is a great one the lab alone
did not decrease
premature births it was the total health
care
system that helped focus on those
patients
um you will hear why are you doing this
you're just a lab
you know you don't need to be doing this
so you need to be prepared
to explain the value that you can bring
to the table
you need to have a champion outside the
lab
i'm sure you've heard the phrase a
prophet has
no honor in their own house and this is
particularly true
when the laboratory is trying to
embed themselves to work with those
outside the laboratory system
in order to produce value you need to
align
your priorities and the things that
you're going to focus on
with those around you and in your
organization
what are their top initiatives and how
can you support that
there's a significant amount of data
security requirements
and even though we may your your team
may all
speak the same language the truth is
is when you have an integrated team
there's different technical and clinical
terminology
that people have to learn i always
jokingly say
i don't speak i.t i can barely spell i.t
and that's one thing that you really
have to to take
time to let the team learn and work
together
there are some references for the
discussion that i've had today with you
and i want to end with this
if you're interested in learning more
about joining the conversation of how
your lab can do this
please join us as part of the project
santa fe foundation
your participation is welcome project
santa fe is a not-for-profit
organization
with two clear objectives one
is to provide thought leadership in this
area
and help labs build
evidence for how they can improve care
and decrease
costs thank you so much for today
i appreciate it have a great day